hello i'm eric horvitz chief scientific
officer at microsoft
it's my privilege to moderate a
discussion on large-scale neural
platform models opportunities concerns
and directions
i'm joined by three fabulous colleagues
percy liang yejin choi and miles
brundage
percy is an associate professor of
computer science at stanford university
his research spans numerous topics in
machine learning with a focus on natural
language including robustness
interpretability semantics and reasoning
yiegen is a professor at the paul allen
school of computer science and
engineering at the university of
washington her interests are rooted in
natural language and machine learning
including grounding of meaning and
common sense reasoning spanning common
sense about the physical and social
worlds
miles is a research scientist at open ai
where he heads up policy research he
focuses on the responsible governance of
ai and he's been a voice
for quite a while around ai safety and
longer term futures
percy agent and miles thank you so much
for joining me today to discuss an
important and interesting
constellation of topics all coming to
the fore quite rapidly over the last
five years or so with the rise of an
interesting paradigm of ai research i
viewed as a tidal shift in an approach
based on leveraging large-scale neural
language models massive models built via
self-supervised
machine learning now a relatively small
number of large-scale neural models have
evolved
into veritable computing platforms for
air and d
where fixed large-scale platform models
are adapted via fine-tuning methodology
to develop capabilities on specific
tasks
while there's great excitement about
demonstrated capabilities the models as
platforms paradigm is at the same time
raising questions and concerns including
on the nature and understandability of
emergent behaviors on the safety and
robustness of the models
and concerns about costly failures such
as the potential for these systems to
generate offensive or misleading output
worries about misuses uh for new powers
these models can give to malevolent
actors these questions are made even
more salient with with recent work that
aims the methods that new tasks like
cogeneration and recommendation
these kinds of applications have even
more direct connection to actions being
taken in the open world
and an overriding challenge that we're
seeing coming into the community is the
cost of building these core platform
models leading to habs and have-nots
where only a few industry organizations
can construct the platform models
so i'd like to spend our time today
discussing these issues all coming in
the context of the buzz of interest
around the rising centrality of
large-scale neural platform models
let's jump in now with some questions
so percy
you know any kind of surprising
emergent behavior draws great attention
in ai research for the implications that
something bigger than expected is coming
out of the methods
and that we might leverage these new
capabilities for leaps forward how would
you characterize
the nature of the emerging capabilities
of these large-scale neural platform
models
yeah thanks eric and thanks for having
me on the panel today this is a topic
that's really near and dear to my heart
these days
um
emergence i think is one of the main
ways i would characterize these type of
platforms or i guess at stanford we've
been calling them foundation models the
um
you know i was immediately struck by
gpg3
by not the text generation but the
ability to do in context learning right
this is something that wasn't programmed
in and just seemed to have emerged
but if you look back at the kind of a
history of how machine learning has
developed even back um you know we can
go back to the kind of early days of
deep learning the idea of
learning features without hand coding
from scratch is a type of kind of early
form of emergence where you don't like
edges or faces or cats or whatever kind
of concepts
just
come out um
from just end-to-end training
um and then with things like bert around
you know 2019 we see that language
models could learn certain types of
syntax again in a very unsupervised way
um but gbe gb3 kind of tops it off with
kind of in context learning which is i
would say
uh much more structural it's kind of an
abstract skill rather than some property
of a
particular modality
um so so i think scientifically this is
really really fascinating
um it does change the kind of way we
think about building ei systems in a way
normally in engineering
you design a system to solve a
particular problem like translate
sentences but with foundation
foundation or platform models you first
train this huge model in a
self-supervised way and then it's like
scientific scientific discovery you go
in and you see
what has it learned what can it do
so this is really you know as a
scientist i'm really excited uh but it
also means that these models are really
poorly understood
and even when they seem to like they if
i can learn something like syntax or um
in context learning
what they're actually learning is really
unclear because we know that they have
lots of failure modes you know as well
and also you know i think we've only
touched on perhaps the surface what
these are capable of these are the
things that we've discovered it might be
that there's other phenomena lurking
even in existing
existing models such as gpd3 that you
know we don't know about and this is um
let alone the future model so gpg4 or
any of the platform models developed uh
today they could harbor a lot of other
things i mean also thinking about
multi-modality and things that just kind
of opens up a whole dimension so i think
there are
um you know opportunities here well
there's a lot to be understood um i
think you know on the
kind of the responsible ability side i
think there's
kind of um
reason to think a bit more carefully
about
we're building you know as you say our
ai ecosystem
around these models and to have them
built on the kind of things that just
emerge is maybe
potentially problematic so i think we
should really question um what we're
building ai systems on top of
um what excites you most about the power
you've seen in these models
and what kind of applications have you
been developing
uh i always like to catch up with with
some of your late-breaking directions
what's happening on your team
um yeah sure um actually yeah before
going there the power and also the
limitations um which does um motivate
which applications
so um
i think a lot of us got very excited and
surprised by how much of fluent language
gpt-3
can generate
but at the same time when we ask very
simple questions
uh common sense questions and depending
on how we phrase it
uh it can perform quite badly
and when i think about it i think it's
the question of a pattern versus core
concept or surface patterns versus
underlying core concept learning and so
it seems that we realize that the
machines the way that machines find
a particular
intelligent ability easy versus heart is
very different from the way we
understand what's easy versus hard for
humans so we would think that writing
fluent blog post
so that human readers come and engage
should be much harder than answering a
very short trivial common sense
questions about
apples birds and you know how many eyes
does a horse have and that sort of
questions
and i think um
this is an interesting new insight about
what machines
can
struggle with and
especially the knowledge core knowledge
and when i say knowledge i'm not just
talking about two plus two is four kind
of knowledge it's also um
uh expanding to
social norms and moral norms and ethical
norms that humans rely on in order to
live day-to-day lives safely and
fairly with each other so
i'm beginning to realize that
scale alone might not be able to
bring all this underlying knowledge
about the society and
how the world works the social and
physical world works and we might need
to find a way to teach machines
that knowledge so um at the same time
this pattern and core concept these two
things are not entirely separate they're
in the continuum which means these
larger scale models are learning a great
deal of the core concept when they are
close to the surface patterns and people
spoke it out loud so
machines probably do know that sky
the color of the sky is usually blue
just because people tend to report to
that in the in the language whereas
nobody talks about how many eyes a horse
has therefore mushy may not know yet let
me just let me ask you and maybe open it
up to anybody
on the panel what are the limits uh in
the ability of these models to actually
learn
deep meaning versus shallow
associational knowledge can can deep
rich semantics
emerge with these transformer models
with training based on just masking and
prediction the way we do self-supervised
uh training if not what more on getting
back to the agent's comments and
insights what more might need to be done
to provide
these representations with deeper
knowledge and deeper meaning
anybody feel free to jump in
i can continue or i could wait for um
go ahead jen yeah please
you're on a roll
yeah so um
some recent research we did which is not
in the public space but it soon will be
uh we investigate algorithms to better
extract more correct knowledge because
off-the-shelf neural models might
produce or generate
sequence of a text that may or may not
represent the correct knowledge but we
found that
well algorithm always has been part of a
computer science and we can use
algorithms in order to
filter
the
uh knowledge down to something more
consistent
and
i think there's a lot of opportunity
there and in our recent work we found
that by doing so we can build a machine
author the symbolic knowledge graph
that's actually better than
the best we humans have written for the
purpose of causal common sense models
and so and this is just one such
approach and i think there's a lot of
opportunity but it might just mean the
importance of
new types of algorithms to better
extract that core concept
and and um
moving to another comment you made and
also uh personally made
beyond language what's in store for
large-scale platform models that might
bring in other modalities like images
video and combine that with language
might we
be able to maybe
seek deeper embodiments that way
heading towards
deeper common sense
wisdom knowledge and these
representations
yeah maybe one thing i would say is that
often people conflate platform or
foundation models with large language
models um and this is just because of
kind of historically how these uh models
evolved from you know with bird and gpg3
from the language domain um but i think
obviously they're much more general just
the idea of you know they are not at
odds with grounding so a lot of the
complaints about how these models don't
really aren't grounded i think you know
if you had much more grounded data the
idea of self-serving vision would
actually be very productive uh there
just like how you know deep learning
evolved from vision but today we don't
think of deep learning as like you know
specific to um you know vision in
particular
but but i do think that there's a lot of
um
uh opportunities in particular video i
think is an extremely promising one
there's and i think you know vision
because of high dimensionality the noise
has requires probably even more kind of
scale and some of them probably other
ideas there to really harness the full
you know potential so i think in the
next few years
even just kind of video alone will
probably have a lot to say and then
there's the kind of interaction between
language and video which i think is
you know super interesting if you look
at these uh even within language um
these multilingual models you could see
that it's um able to kind of take
two
you know languages and kind of embed
them in a in a shared space so that
you're getting at something that's much
more universal than the individual
language and hopefully by combining not
just different languages but different
modalities
we might be able to see even kind of
more
kind of learning of the
underlying concepts
let me jump to miles miles what excites
you about the possibilities forward for
large-scale neural models
where are things headed at the research
frontiers of these models and maybe at
open air you can tell us what we can
expect next
yeah so i think
so first of all there there's a lot of
low-hanging fruit of just doing more of
the same and you know get get even
better results so more compute more data
you know more more more parameters uh
but i think what's more interesting than
just scaling up is doing things
differently so uh using different
objectives and different ways of
combining human feedback to steer the
system so that they're not just you know
trying to predict what comes next in in
a string of texts in the same way that
it would you know as if it had seen it
on the internet so trying to model the
internet that's you know that that does
lead to interesting behaviors and does
lead to an efficient way of soaking up
knowledge but at the end of the day we
don't want a simulation of the internet
we want a system that actually solves
problems uh so for example one thing
that we've been working on at openai is
training systems to follow instructions
so it's not just you give it you know
five examples and then you expect that
the sixth sixth line of text will be
similar to the first five lines you say
uh you know instead of giving examples
of poems you just say write a poem in
the style of x
and it sort of learns through human
feedback with human labelers and uh you
know what we call reward modeling uh to
actually perform the tasks in a way that
that is aligned with the human intention
and similarly we there are other sorts
of ways of of uh doing things
differently so breaking problems uh into
smaller chunks so just yesterday uh
opening i published a paper uh on
recursive summarization of books where
instead of you know just trying to read
read an entire book
and summarize it in one shot which is a
hard problem and goes beyond the length
of uh length of text that the gp3 can
handle you summarize small chunks and
then summarize a few different chunks
into a bigger chunk and and so on up the
chain uh and this this is interesting
both uh in that it can allow us to solve
different kinds of problems and it also
allows us to oversee how the how gpd3 is
actually solving these problems and and
sort of exam check its work at each step
of the way and i think you know not not
just getting better performance but
better ways of overseeing these systems
is something i'm really excited about
yeah maybe i can add a little bit to
that just a kind of complimentary
perspective i often think of these
models as kind of unfinished incomplete
models you know they're a platform or a
foundation that you need to build on top
of so i think you know in some ways it's
not that these models are directly uh
should be deployed out like you're not i
don't think we should be deploying to a
user like the raw output of gpt3
um
and and so i think it's interesting to
think about
what would be what should we build what
should a kind of a platform foundation
you know look like so that the myriad
set of uh you know people application
developers can harness this technology
in a kind of understandable way to build
various you know applications that
you know they would want and what should
that interface look like of course we
have questions percy about the the
nature of what the platform or
foundation model should look like we
also have questions about what should
the fine tuning or the process by which
we you know
we sort of generate application and user
applications be like as well yeah yeah i
mean there's also a whole pipeline from
the data language where is the data
coming from how is it curated what are
the privacy how do you think about
privacy and you know data dignity and
things like that yeah i find it great to
be in a field where
uh one panelist says uh you know we're
publishing something uh you know just
yesterday or tomorrow and another
panelist says i haven't published this
yet but you should hear about this i'm
so excited so things are moving pretty
quickly it's interesting
now let me ask the group let me start
with miles about concerns about safety
responsibility
uh various ethical questions rising with
the uses of these models at least the
current versions of them and the
fine-tuning process currently in place
we can imagine this changing someday we
can even comment on how we might change
things in the future to address some of
those issues but what are the current
concerns about
safety responsibility and more generally
some of the ethical questions that have
come up with these models
yeah so i i think the way i put it is
that uh
because these systems are trained on
such a generic objective of just just
sort of you know replicating text and
trying to imitate the internet
essentially uh that means that they can
be used for a lot of good as well as bad
and uh misguided purposes so i would
break the issue down into misuse where
you know that's just like simulating the
text is just not something we want to do
so we don't want models where you give
it a false headline and it generates a
whole uh you know whole sort of uh you
know new york times style article about
about some some fake thing that didn't
actually happen and then you know
someone spews it all over the internet
so i would you know consider that a kind
of misuse problem where just the
objective that these models are trained
on is not something we want to support
and at open ai we do things like having
rate limits and quotas and uh sort of
you know anomaly detection for for you
know patterns that might be correlated
with those sorts of things so uh so that
that sort of misuse there's also unsafe
use and and just uses for which the
model is too immature it doesn't have
enough world knowledge it might you know
have it it might be a domain where
there's a higher risk of generating
toxic outputs or or medically harmful
outputs for example if you're using it
for medical advice there be cases where
its biases could cause serious harm such
as asking it to uh to you know make loan
decisions for example so uh you know the
the way that we think about that is that
you know we uh we're still treating this
as sort of a beta phase of of deployment
and over time we're gradually scaling up
the amount of people and the amount of
use cases we can support uh but for a
lot of things that are uh you know high
risk we just won't be able to support
them and we can you know we're just not
going to approve you know say you know
generating a billion tokens of text a
day for you know for some random purpose
that it has to be you know uh something
that's consistent with our guidelines
and there's also
there's also the question of you know
sort of what kinds of bells and whistles
like documentation and a human in the
loop
are allowed to make a a system that's
not on our sort of red list and not not
too high risk but it's borderline and
you know potentially a yellow light uh
and you know are there ways that you can
make that better such as by having an
informed user and making sure that
there's always a human in the loop so i
think there's a sort of a spectrum of
things from very low risk to very high
risk and a lot in between yeah and percy
and agent go ahead please
yeah i would be excited to build on what
miles just said um
so uh
two things in addition so about the
toxic language generation uh for me
the reason why machines do that is
really because that's what humans said
in raw text out there and so not only
this
presents an opportunity to
reduce such harmful language from ai i
think we might also be able to better
guide or inform people to
avoid the bias the language because
oftentimes such a language is used by
people who believe that they have a zero
bias
and
another
interesting potentially interesting
but in my heart a very important
research direction to pursue
is
in case these models become so powerful
and become really even more deeply
integrated with the human lives i think
we need to really inject
some sense of social norms and moral
norms into these models better so that
it's not just about avoiding harmful
things when generating texts but also
understanding in general what are
socially normative behavior
and uh so this is a little bit more
forward-looking perhaps but um
yeah another coming up uh work that i
think eric you saw the preview of it
recently is um common sense moral models
that can do a lot of qa um in it it's
taught by um basically human written
textbook of a moral norms and code that
machines on its own cannot really
decipher by reading a lot of raw text
which have a questionable
things such as you know maybe writing a
fake news is okay thing to do
which um
is natural so it's almost similar to how
as humans we have to teach our children
what's right and what's wrong and i
don't think it's right for us to expect
that machines can do that on their own
self-supervised discovery of moral norms
i don't believe that's possible and we
have to teach more explicit explicitly
through declarative knowledge
yes it's interesting it's another
challenge that i've seen recently with
playing with
uh the output of in some of these tasks
created with the platform models in
language has been
what i what i'm calling instead of like
analogous to the uncanny valley in in in
user interface research in hci
is what i call the hidden valleys of
looking at pieces of text that seem
almost correct but you have to sort of
look at it very carefully to find that
wait a minute that's not true
uh and so there's a concern that within
in daily uses people might not put the
effort in to see the kind of hidden
valleys of
of erroneous information uh even if
if shrouded by um
more correct sounding text or inferences
uh
personally any comments on on the you
know what your your sense perspective
your lens on safety ethics
responsibility yeah yeah lots of
comments i mean i think this is a great
topic um and we could have a whole panel
on ai uh your responsibility our whole
workshop oh i know we've been through
those panels overseas
yeah and and i think it's it's
especially important because i think you
know there's a a lot of work on kind of
pushing the technology and business as
usual kind of scaling up and it seems
like we actually i mean they're very
hard challenges but there's kind of a
seems like a path but i think ai
responsibility is fundamentally much
less developed and partly because it
kind of intrinsically involves not just
you know a bunch of computer scientists
or ai people but we need to think about
the social scientists and the people
studying
science
and and technology and society um as
well i mean i guess the way i think
about it there's a kind of a spectrum of
um you know subtle to catastro there's
like kind of subtle biases to kind of
let's say misuse and kind of mistakes to
kind of existential risk and i thought i
heard the word catastrophic being formed
on your lips just now
yeah um and i think well all three are
kind of
um
you know different maybe
i i'm projecting it onto a kind of
single axis but maybe different
timelines slash kind of different um uh
intensity levels i want to pick up on
the the first though these kind of
biases um because i think these are
probably the hardest to spot and the
ones where you kind of can it's like the
frog that kind of gets um you know
boiled alive if you you don't really pay
attention to the gently warming frying
pan yeah and and i think it's um you
know bias obviously as we've talked
about is present in the data and it gets
reflected and you know we talked a lot
about kind of the degenerative
applications and they're um it's
sometimes easier to see where biases
creep up it's especially maybe easy to
see when toxic content comes but these
biases let's say you're doing
recommendation systems or you're doing
kind of uh your web page you know
ranking which are you know
already kind of powered by these you
know platform or foundation models um
you know these are kind of much more in
the background right like we talk about
gv3 and we we see what the model is
doing but i think
most of the the impact of these models
is going to be completely invisible
users will not see it but it will
suddenly affect you know what web pages
rank um and what what people see and if
you're basing these on kind of much more
personalized information now we can have
kind of more of an amplification of
biases and the problem with bias is that
there's also a feedback loop where you
deploy these models and
behavior changes and the data that you
collect to retrain these models
is going to kind of harden and entrench
these biases even further so i think
this is a really important
topic to
think about and i know there's a lot of
work kind of in the lb community
thinking about you know biases already
and one thing that would be great to do
is kind of connect
the the intrinsic notions of evaluation
of bias of the language models to their
kind of end extrinsic harms that they do
when they are adapted and deployed to
real applications
and of course it's the case that we're
already immersed in
all of us
on civilization these days in in
numerous recommender engines search
engines other kinds of proxization from
media to purchasing
uh
to location
uh to services and so it's not just
large language
large-scale platform models that are
have these troubles but um it's it's
it's always something we're grappling
with as a
society let me uh change pivot just a
bit i mean not to give any short trip to
these very important topics that could
take hours and weeks of discussion to
even converge
on on definitions at times
percy in starting with percy is access
uh and and
and computing
a growing challenge for university-based
researchers uh what and and i think the
answer is going to be yes of course but
what are some directions for
democratizing the technology how might
academic research be better supported
yeah yeah the answer is a
resounding yes
i i think that
you know
you know one of the things that we don't
really appreciate enough about the deep
learning revolution is this uh
incredible amount of democratization or
openness and transparency right which
where people show your share code and
data sets and you could just kind of get
tutorials and allowed a lot of
researchers and ai startups and people
to develop this but
these models are kind of reverting these
and sometimes the code and data sets and
you know also the models um aren't being
released anymore released anymore so
it's kind of hard to
have researchers kind of be part of this
you know conversation
and i think that this is you know
important because of
the such the wide range of social impact
that this is going to have that we just
need um not not just academia but just
like as many kind of diverse voices as
as possible kind of analyzing critiquing
auditing figuring out and shaping the
development rather than having it be
concentrated in a few kind of
the the people who have you know this
technology
um and so i also point out that you know
one could say
well why do you need you know um i i
should say that um it's important to be
able to train these models right so
you know several models have been
released um and a lot of research good
work has been happening on understanding
what the models are
but but i think the the thing is that
the object of study is shouldn't be the
model that it should be
the process like machine learning is
about how data
you take data and you turn into a model
that is useful for predictions which
means that you need to think about
um intervening on changing architecture
changing the data
and seeing how these things manifest and
without the ability to do that um then
you're just not able to even ask the
right kind of research you know
questions there
so um
you know what's the way forward
well
um i think that's that's a very good
question i think that
um oh so the other thing i'll mention is
that you know it's
some work can be done at smaller scales
um but but because of emergence because
in context learning doesn't show up at
1.3 billion parameters it shows up at
you know
at least maybe
10 billion and you see it kind of in
full swing at 175
you just miss certain things if you're
only kind of working at scale so that's
another challenge you need to train and
you need to do it at scale
so what what can we do about this um so
this is where obviously your industry
and academia should kind of jointly
figure out
you know solution and figuring out a way
to provide you know access um you know
to
um to academia of not just kind of the
models but the ability to train and
ability to kind of be part of this you
know conversation
um and that's i think
you know also we need to invest in kind
of public infrastructure so you know
stanford was involved in initiating this
kind of national research cloud at least
for
a us uh you know it's still kind of you
know very early days but i think we also
could benefit from having much more
public infrastructure for sustaining um
kind of open academic research at a kind
of a national level
any other comments on that miles or you
didn't
yeah go ahead
but most if you
wanted to yeah yeah well i'll just say a
brief thing which is that
i think you know even i i also agree
it'd be good to have more public
infrastructure on this and uh i think
you know having sort of academic
involvement in the training process
would definitely be uh having more of
that would be valuable i think it's also
an interesting question of you know what
is the best way uh what is the best set
of norms for actors like open eye and
google and others to make the models
that they do have uh you know
transparent in a way that
checks off the various boxes of
reproducibility and uh and sort of
supporting academic research and uh and
uh you know while still and as well as
um you know creativity and the arts and
and uh other sorts of uses which may not
be sort of commercially commercially
viable uh given that these are often you
know expensive you know should these be
sort of heavily subsidized should there
be uh you know sort of should it be free
for academics i think it's an
interesting question of of how you sort
of best support that uh and you know
what what should the norms be around you
know should there's sort of be a right
to audit all of these systems that are
being deployed uh you know when when you
know sort of investigative journalists
and other actors want to poke them for
biases you know at opening eye we've
been trying to to be pretty liberal in
this and provide uh access to these
models but there's also some limits on
uh you know sort of we we do have some
rate limits for security reasons and
preventing misuse and you know what is
the right balance between these things
uh to between transparency and
auditability on the one hand and and
misuse prevention i think is an
interesting question and it would be
great to see sort of you know some some
convergence around norms uh for for what
to do with these existing models while
we also think about uh better
infrastructure
yeah so while i agree with everything
that you said so far i would like to add
a different angle to this which is that
um
although it's important for academics
also uh being able to study the
internals of creating these models i
think academic people can also do
complementary research that builds on
these models from outside
and then be able to come up with really
creative methods that could overcome
any issues in the data for example if
there were biased language or
misinformation
picked up by the model is there an
algorithmic way to
suppress that or even disable it
because humans are able to learn to do
that even if we were raised
in a culture where maybe um
uh you know you know gender norms were
very different or there may have been
more integrated the sexism in the
culture
one can still change as they age and
also they
learn other cultures they might uh
change their mind and we are perfectly
capable of this continual learning
and i think we could do that with these
um
large-scale models as well and for that
i almost feel like this is an implicit
collaboration between academics and
companies like microsoft and open ai
and you know for my research i feel like
there's a definite or many research
there's some you know definite shift be
before gpt3 and after gpt3 a lot of the
new research um can build on gpt3's
capability and even the fact that we can
probe what gpt does not know or what
sort of a toxic or biased language it
might generate it really gives a lot of
insights to academic people about the
importance of such research and how we
might go about
these limitations really questioning the
fundamentals and i don't think
all of us should work on these
quote unquote foundation models for that
reason we should also invest a lot on
what to do on tap
yeah thank you thanks again i should say
that we're we're doing some exploration
ourselves with the the turing academic
program with sharing out those models
and working together to learn more
from our university colleagues on on how
to work together and how to complement
one another as well as pushing on the
core science let me ask um
everybody what might the border of what
we call platform versus
fine-tuning
of these models shift or even melt in
the future for example with the
availability of more
powerful computation or new methods of
with how the models are are are tuned or
extended with massive data corpora
well we kind of
seen convergence and a fixation on the
current kind of approach to
uh to to handling uh generating and
using these large-scale um platform
models
yeah i think already there's uh you know
the the line is fairly blurry um i think
in you know an academic culture it's
easy to think about pre-training and
then fine-tuning
but but you know in practice you have a
pre-trained model maybe on some text and
then you continue pre-training on some
other text so you can kind of think
about tree of possibilities and they
adapt it and it kind of gets more
adapted to the fine-grained task that's
one thing and the other thing is that
there's feedback right now you know
now you deploy the system maybe you get
data now you have to go back and you
know retrain your your system so kind of
this up model updating and uh
retraining is something that's i think
really important because these are not
models that you want to kind of train
every day um but but nonetheless in real
world deployments the world changes and
you need up i'll update them
um and then not to mention some of the
things around kind of learning that
miles mentioned around learning from
human feedback and um
getting additional pieces of information
which maybe uh
um depends on what the model is doing so
there's a lot of kind of cyclical stuff
so i think
um you know you think about the free
training and fine tuning that's the kind
of one course way of looking at one
piece of the the puzzle right now
any other comments on that
i mean i would just say that you know
i'm i continue to be surprised how far
you can push uh you know foundation
models large language models or platform
models you know whatever you want to
want to call them in the case of gpd3
for example like there's just so much
you can do even without fine tuning
which i find really remarkable and and
even entirely new kinds of things that
that weren't you know
we didn't mention in the original paper
and you know people didn't really find
good good applications for several
months like you know a year plus later
people are starting to to think
seriously about uh uh using these
systems as data generators and then uh
sort of fine to fine-tuning models based
on the the data that is generated of a
certain type and then you have an even
better model that's trained on that and
yes agent is excited about that
direction as well so i i think you know
even without fine tuning there's a lot
and i think we barely scratch the
surface of of what's possible with
fine-tuning these models as well so
there's you know it's really hard to say
uh you know how things will evolve
yeah i was going to say that
just we're getting close to our time now
but did it talk a bit more broadly you
know over the years uh in ai research
and i've been doing this research for
long enough where i've seen specific
waves of excitement
uh
rolling over the community and they
might be viewed some of the previous
ones as akin to a monkey racing up to
the top of a tree
exhilarated about being on the path to
getting to the moon but hitting a dead
end
are these platform
models foundation models in this
approach are they on the critical path
to more powerful more general
ai capabilities or might we view the
models as
and the whole paradigm is being a local
maxima in some ways exciting and
interesting with learnings for all of us
but not necessarily on the path to
achieving long-term dreams of ai
including for example
uh it's not just an example including
the pursuit of the multiple what i like
to refer to as the standing mysteries of
human intellect
yeah i can begin
i would be very surprised if these go
away in the you know foreseeable future
i mean even if you look at
historically even you know machine
learning
right you developed and you can wonder
um you know whether machine learning is
is essential and part of the solution
you know back in the 90s i think this
was maybe more of a
debate um
and it's not that machine learning has
gone away it's still very much with us
it's just that we think about kind of a
different level and then there's deep
learning you could ask well does deep
learning has it is it the future well um
again debates and it's not that deep
learning has gone away now we have
platform models deep learning is the
kind of the thing that powers you know a
platform or foundation models and then
the same with foundation models i think
it's it's a tool based on self
supervision this generates a certain set
of capabilities but i think over time
i think the framing and the way we view
these technologies will definitely
change but i think these these critical
components will um remain and hopefully
they'll get a lot better um more robust
and you know reliable and more efficient
but i think that's idea of um
building
the idea of generally building um
you know
shareable infrastructure for a bunch of
eye systems seems like a generally of
fairly some safe bet right machine
learning has traditionally suffered from
you know this uh narrow idea you can
only you train on the one data set and
it doesn't even generalize to uh
something a different data set and now
we kind of have a much more general way
you know of doing things the other final
thing i'll add is that you know these i
don't think i mean part of these models
deep down bothers me because they don't
you know having as someone who's worked
on kind of more
logical um you know somatic parsing
methods they don't really i mean they
don't understand
um in the same way that we would like to
but but i think that
that's a bit maybe beside the the point
i think of them as a very very good
system one
like they're incredibly good guessers
soak in all the contacts what's your gut
reaction what's the next word or what's
generate something and i think we need
still a system too something that um
really
kind of keeps our head on our shoulders
in a way
that's something we haven't really kind
of you know figured out i guess there's
things that in in the past that maybe
don't scale and we need to kind of
complete that picture of system one and
system two to really have uh fulfill as
you put it
you know ai dreams in some sense
any comments on that yeah i personally i
think a skill is a
necessary but not sufficient condition
to
making that leap to the moon
and um so what's missing well i'm going
to bet on knowledge concept learning
proper concept learning i mean even if
we add logic on top i don't think we are
going to go very far without really
teaching questions how to learn correct
knowledge current correct concept
learning and um
uh
the the work that i think miles
mentioned uh in passing earlier about
data generation offer from gpt3
in my mind it's also a form of
symbolic knowledge distillation offered
from gpt3 and i think
um
the true capability right now gpt3 is
fascinating because of a prompt
engineering and because of
long-form text generation but i think we
still haven't discovered what we are
capable of offer from these extreme
scale neural models
and in order to get to the moon we
really have to get out of the current
learning paradigm paradigm and then look
for new things that we can do that are
different and i i want to emphasize the
knowledge angle being a probably
important missing piece going forward
okay miles
yeah i mean i would just add that i i
like a framing that um uh that raucom
potty from her uh triple ai president
and
one of my professors of ai back in the
day uh yeah he refers these systems as
uh having uh sort of wide but shallow
knowledge and uh compared to a lot of
previous systems that were narrow and
deep uh in their areas of expertise and
i think you know they it's just a very
different type of you know intelligence
or understanding than we're used to and
you know they they they're able to you
know they're in some respects superhuman
like no human can you know generate uh
you know a you know hybridized two types
of poetry and you know generate you know
10 pages of you know that hybrid and you
know in a few milliseconds it's it's
quite remarkable the things that you can
do with these systems but then they're
just incredibly you know incredibly far
short of human understanding in a lot of
areas so i think that that's sort of my
main update has been less about sort of
the path to the path to you know
powerful ai and agi uh you know looking
differently and more just like you know
rethinking you know how how we
understand intelligence and what what
that path looks like as opposed to how
far we are away from it
well well thanks percy yejin and miles
um for
a fun and interesting discussion we're
out of time unfortunately we'll have to
continue uh in other meetings uh so
research continues at a really fast pace
and it's clear we have a lot to learn
about uh these um foundation or platform
uh neural models
i'm really excited to see how our
understandings are gonna grow and our
methods are going to evolve over time
it's going to be interesting hey can we
um the four of us
make a date now
i was thinking to meet up in 10 years
let's say in the fall of 2031 and we'll
look back at
how things went or where they went uh to
discuss what came with the ideas uh that
was shared today in our discussion
it will certainly be interesting to see
uh how
our current intuitions and reflections
will be viewed from that future point in
time
thank you percy yejin and miles for
sharing your insights and perspectives
with us today
thank you eric thank you thank you